ja ich begrüße ich erzählt sich und wir
heute in dieser sitzung heute dann alles
auch nur sie wissen es ist als wenn sich
reden
warum ich lasse mich gehen
die saison nutzen sie zum also ich sag
mal was zur formalen anlage der des
seminars also heute geht es nicht um
herrn die erste position in unserem
programm
der ist ganz zentral für anzahl thema
jetzt zu sagen der einstieg und die
leitfrage sind noch nicht gesagt haben
wie wird der kuss von biologisch begriff
des triebes von leibnitz leib jetzt
nicht so sehr mit ihrer bisherigen
philosophische geprägt und systematisch
integriert also bei leibnitz muss man
sagen bei leibnitz ist der trieb noch
nicht so als trieb etablieren da gibt's
dann eben verschiedene kräfte die
wirkung bleibt uns ist vielleicht immer
im hintergrund aber wir wollen mit
hertha wirklich beginnen wir gehen
bisher gelegen sondern später bediente
schritt machen dann fragen uns immer
wenn sie die texte lesen welche rolle
spielt der trieb weil er da werden wir
sehen dass sie die kraft betrieb setzte
tages dann ist oder persönliche diese
von mir dass der triebe griff sich
besonders deswegen eignet weil die
brücke zwischen theorie zwischen kenne
und der praxis den hanteln leisten also
ohne tee sind kann man diskutieren
dann kann man es wagen ihr findet euch
der lebens begriff adäquat angegeben ist
durch den tri begriff und wenn die
aktualität dieser tür steht
sicherlich werden sie es nicht aufnehmen
können mit aktuellen motto
zwischendurch naturwissenschaftlichen
theorien aber wir können steht noch ein
gast aus somalia methode habe ich schon
gesagt systematisch über den tri begriff
diskutieren wir wollen von anderen
verwandten begriffen abgrenzen
wissen sie noch ein paar andere begriffe
die ähnlich sind die begriffe und sie
dann rannten dienen was war denn zum
ende gekämpft
wir hatten das an die tafel geschrieben
ich kann mir auch noch ein paar kollegen
mit wenn sie einfach mal ein paar
begriffe noch die wir hier genannt habe
in dem betrieb begriff appetit daran
genau also schrittes marschieren ganz
ordentlich mit einem schulden stift habe
ich das jetzt mal hin
also wir haben appetit was haben wir
noch
das ist ein schöner nachzuschauen was
und motivation
genau
motivation das motiv was wissen sie was
motiv wörtlich heißt motiven wie grund
genau als morgen wäre bewegen motiv
motors wird die bewegung also es hängt
mit der bewegung des zahlen kann sie
noch mehr antritt
was kommt denn bei her darauf vor er
bekommt keinen begriff also trieb konnte
aber ich nur ein paar mal ich habe mal
gezählt nur zwei bis dreimal bis welcher
begriff kam anders nach vorn
wer verspricht gefällt
ja also bestimmt ist schnell dahin als
entwicklung
ich wollte immer schöner es wird immer
besser entwicklung
ich denke dem sie machen es ja
entwicklung aber betrieb antrieb treibt
zur entwicklung hin
also die entwicklung ist die folge die
konsequenz des triebeser kraft genannten
kraft ist das entscheidende kraft
deswegen unterstreiche seine kraft kraft
ist jetzt aber eigentlich was du an den
griff aus welcher bis zu den containern
heutzutage geredet noch von kraft man in
verschiedenen wissenschaftlichen also
für sich physik genau es gibt
verschiedene kräfte sind wissen sie die
starke kraft die schwache kraft er mit
thomas kraft gibt es noch eine alte
seele verschiedene art betreffen aber in
der regel wird kraft geben als einen
physikalischen angriffe verwandten
bildungsgrad zu sein
richtig jens kraft wäre dann eher sowas
wie die motivation
das wäre dann die eine metapher könnte
man sagen muss nicht sein
ich glaube nicht unbedingt dass es eine
toughe ist weil ich glaube ihr das kraft
ein so grundsätzlicher begriff ist dass
er einfach lebensweltlich ganz fest
verankert ist zb dann zu sagen diese
person ist kräftiger als diesen
da würden sie sicherlich nicht den
begriff der kraft metaphorisch befinden
oder ob mir jemand kräftig ist stark
stärke kraft
ich denke dass das alles aus demselben
lebensweltlich im kontext kommt noch
andere begriffe die sie sich noch
doch passend zum giftes triebe sind
bestrebung strebe streben genommen
bestreben das sage ich jetzt mal
bestrebung ist in diesem kontext streben
ziele im ziel und vom streben kommen
natürlich ganz schnell auf die natur mit
der natur
da ist ja alles strebt jetzt endlich
nach verschiedene auffassungen haben
also steckt simulations- tmgs gibt
irgendwelche ziele auf eine
evolutionstheorie absolutes ziel hinzu
aber es gibt gewisse tendenzen diese
richtung
und dank da fällt mir noch ein weiter
begriff eine jetzt nicht direkt mit der
kraft zu tun hat aber der die
entwicklung ist was denkt man hätte
welche begriff welcher begriff es werde
ganz zu tun er hat er seit nicht diese
entwicklung ist es etwas anderes blick
auf die menschen die natur entwickelt
sich der mensch ja
[Musik]
das ist die these von herbert wiese auf
die rauswahl friedens gleich wieder auf
den text ein dementen helga möchte dass
der mensch veranstaltet in seiner
entwicklung oder unter seiner und seine
geistige entwicklung und die nennt man
häufig auch wenn man an der universität
in tunis was lernt ja transzendenz kann
damit zusammenhängen dass zitiert sei
einfacher bildung bildung
wieder müssen zentrale begriffe mehr
also trieb und medium hängen irgendwie
zusammen bildung ist jetzt natürlich
auch wieder eine ganz interessante
brauche weil bildung ebenso eine
doppeldeutigkeit hat in natürliche seite
hat wie auch eine geistige seite bildung
kann bedeutet er sich zum beispiel
pflanzen fonds bilden pflanzen
entwickeln das sich herausbildet ein
kristall kann sich heraus bild aber auch
ein mensch kann sich bilden kann sich
geistig entwickeln also die bildung und
der trieb wie ohne grund nennt der
nächste denke die wir befördern mit dem
wir uns befassen wer den nächsten
sitzung dass der blumen er spricht von
bildungs trieb auch bildungsträger ist
in den doppeldeutigkeit verstehen
nämlich einerseits bezogen auf den
menschen auf seine geistige entwicklung
hat seine bildung aber auch sein
natürlich entwickelt dass man sieht
entry begriff ist die natur und die
vernunft gewissermaßen ganz eng
aufeinander bezogen
sie sehe das hier anhand unserer
verschiedene begriffe appetit ist eher
was natürliches ich habe hunger ist
natürliches streben motivation dass sie
schon motivation da sind häufig gründe
mit im spiel
beweggründe die sitzen motivation i tät
vertragsfrei sehen hier ist denn ihr so
dieser freiheit streben hingegen kann
beides sein streben kann einerseits
natürlich tendenz beinhaltet aber auch
keine
unter dem trelle tendenz wenn wir uns
bestimmte ziele setzen und schreibt hier
noch bis 7 daneben ziehen
wir streben auf 1 zählern ein ziel
setzen die uns selbst geregelt wir haben
natürlich in uns eine regierung
anstreben geben die fenster natur also
hier sehen sie wieder ihr kommen
natürlich auch gleich die ganze frage
sind wir frei oder nicht aber ohne frage
serbien mit streben versehen ob jetzt
seid frei sind und nicht wir sind als
natürliche wesen streben gewesen die
auch etwas hinziehen aristoteles sagt in
seiner schrift mit der physik ist es
glaube ich dass alle menschen von natur
aus zum wissen strebe eine tendenz die
leute mit tendenz nach osters tendenz
wer also einen richter sind ausrichten
kraft ist sicherlich ein ganz zentraler
begriff
also sind nur so bald nicht wieder
benutzereingaben sie mit seiner
natürlichen geistiger natur und mit
geist gleichermaßen zu tun natur und
geist oder vermutlich in dieser spannung
zwischen atom vernunft steht der trieb
begriff den wir jetzt in diesem seminar
wir haben werden
ich denke so kann man das
veranschaulicht
und wie kann man diese spannung zwischen
natur im betrieb dieser natürlichen
trieb aber auch der vernünftige trieb so
was wie zwecke wie ziele setzen wie kann
man diese stamm auflösen das ist die
frage die wir dieses immer die
klassische deutsche philosophie wollen
wir kennen werden wir haben also ich hab
gesagt leibnitz werde ich ab und zu ein
bisschen auf darauf zu sprechen konnte
er wird nicht im zentrum stehen das ist
ein kapitel versichern mit herta beginnt
werden wir kommen auf an kritik denen
ganze sprechen
willkommen auf dem anerkannt ganz
zentral zu sprechen komme zu sprechen so
weit möchte ich sie noch mal hier auf
dieses internetangebot hinweisen
wer von ihnen hat schon mal angeschaut
wie du kannst also schauen sie wir haben
jetzt hier ganz aktuell 1080 1108 haben
ganz ordentlich und hier sehen sind das
die aufnahme der letzten sitzung für
mittlerweile auch hier verlegt
klose 1 1 foto msc und für eine
theoretische das zweifache erbe von
leibnitz terry der petition von der
insel auf dem bild von links aber könnte
sich mal schauen hier finde ich ganz
ganz gut da haben auch die vorstellung
ihres vortrags eingeblendet wenn sie
sich also vermeiden jetzt interessieren
schauen sich das an nicht nach oben
rechts im video nach er auch nicht den
blick jetzt zum einen zu diesem foto und
da gibt es eben die app der für den hat
sie schon diese flugangst rp morgen
laden sie sich unters kostenlos die
smartphones hier sehen sie dann ist in
halle bildschirm im ganzen gesehen sich
jetzt zum begriff des triebes in eigenen
reiter wenn sie darauf geben findet sich
eben hier dann alle diese hoch markiert
hier schon zwei einträge zusammensetzung
und die aufzeichnung zu sitzen
das ist sowohl der branche wenn sie das
interessiert kann ich ja auch da
zusammen was wir das täten sich über die
menschen ich finds halt ganz praktisch
mal dass es zum arzt auch für die
hosentasche
sie können zum beispiel in der
straßenbahn aber da muss ich immer mal
warten wenn sie warten müssen schlauer
beim einkaufen
schauen sie kurz rein werden sie sehen
auch die blei tricksen inter textuelle
verknüpft und über links sie können von
einblicken nächsten springen
also hat sich ganz gut bewertet nur so
als struktur des hergangs jetzt kommen
wir zu diesen nicht mehr gott johann
gottfried herder der as st der steht
hinter allem also der ist wirklich der
bezugspunkt wenn es um betriebe griff
geht in uns gesetzt haben allesamt ihr
widerpart fragen überlegt welche rolle
kommt den trieben nachher dazu inwiefern
unterscheiden zählen verschiedene arten
von 320 tränen aufgegeben und geschichte
zueinander wie verweisen nachher die
triebe eine bestimmte richtung auf sie
haben sich an das streben noch mal
zurück wir haben hier ganz oben hier das
streben streben das ist hier also wohin
ist das ganz gerichtet inwiefern weise
nachher träger eine bestimmte richtung
aufwachen und worauf ziele gibt es so
ein endpunkt dieser entwicklung läuft es
auch ein endziel in das ist so die frau
wir uns stellen werden und dann was
nachher das ziel der menschlichen natur
bieten wie wenig diese doppeldeutigkeit
der menschlichen erklärte ein
natürliches wesen aber er hat auch eine
für den steg zeit an dieser spannung
müssen wir den trieb betrifft begriffen
ist anziehen
so jetzt immer haben sie noch fragen zu
diesem text dem sie bekommen haben wir
machen präsentiert die vorher der wand
und her gehen die folien durch die
zentralsten zitate und diskutierte
gemeinsam also der titel des ersten
abschnitts lautet der schöpfung unserer
erde herrscht eine aufsteigende form
betrifft es haben vielleicht gemerkt wer
da spricht häufig in theologischen
kontext das ganze ist eingebettet in
großen horizont von tradition der stadt
aber auch fraport hat also hat auch fred
wir halten das darf man nicht außen vor
lassen
aber wir sind hier keine theologin und
philosophin und philosophen
wir wollen das ganze also verein aus
historischer sicht betrachten so und
jetzt sagt erfolg dass erstens vom
steitz und kristallen von kristall zu
den metall und diesen zu pflanzen
schöpfen
von den pflanzen zu tieren von diesem
zum menschen sagen wenn die form der
organisation steigen mit ihr auch die
kräfte und ins kommt unser begriff
betriebe des geschäfts vielseitiger
werden und sich endlich alle gestaltetes
mensch
sofern diese sie fassen konnte vereine
die menschen stand die reihe stellen wir
können kein schiff über ihr das
vielseitige oder künstliche organisiert
2 erscheint das höchste und so eine
organisation gebildet werden könnte also
wie ist jetzt noch mal diese ganze
wieder dieser bildung dieser
organisation der geschöpfe
vielleicht sprechen das komma hin
ich lösche das jetzt hier das wir hier
geschrieben haben
schade drum habe erreicht wird und man
das wieder kleinen neben wieder ein
stift und schwarz das ganze also ist das
ganze organisiert was steht ganz
natürlich der trieb das ist ganz klar
der trieb ist mir ganz gut
kommt jetzt wenn sie das zitat sich
vergeben werden ganz am anfang
wenn sie das als ein aufsteigen das
system mit drachen haben also hier ist
in die richtung es geht hier noch was
ist ganz einfach
ja genau wenn sie noch mal schauen hier
organisch ist auch die christen
ja genau alles mal jemand stein stein
dann kommt das teil
und das ist das anorganische könnte man
würde man heutzutage genau mitteilen
als unternehmer das metall noch hier
hören sie müssen wir wieder spricht ja
ich denke sie haben recht das metall ist
durchaus auch das kann
das metall ist auch an der ungar
besteuerung glaube ich recht oder würden
sie sagen dass das metall gibt ist ja
also nochmal immer das anorganische
anorganisches normalerweise schreibe ich
schön
das hängt natürlich mit so aber ist doch
mal interessant wenn sie sich jetzt mal
hier diese diese entwicklung hier mal
anschauen könnte dem ein bisschen 8 nach
holz was ist da was der sinn dieser
schon bis nach hof mit jahres machen was
ist dieser dahin brauchen wir jetzt ein
kristall meter das ist eine logik die
dahinter steckt wohl erst mal noch ein
kleiner was soll ich über den teil
schreiben was gibt jetzt fallen an
wie muss diese achse diese richtung was
nimmt dazu ja
ja also verfeinerungen stimmt ja auch
für veränderung wollen wir es vielleicht
komplexitäten oder haben sie im besten
fall schon komplexität
oder vielleicht auch noch bildung
bildung bildung
als überhaupt entsteht der steigung
anfang ist getan
also mir nicht ein warum erster stein
und das teilt diese vergangenes wickler
wie würden sie den übergang machen da
ist ja also ich ja ich sage immer meine
thesen und steine zum beispiel ein stein
der ist nicht direkte form und greift
nach einem stein irgendein steigen
satz steigt der brüssel tab das ist so
ein more ford klotz wenn sie kristalle
haben dann haben sie da eine ganz schöne
eine ganze struktur also ein kristall
der der splittert nicht willkürlich wenn
sie im kristall entscheidung also wenn
sie fest ein sehr kleiner dann spielt er
nach ganz bestimmten strukturen
das ist christian hatten erinnere vorne
in der definition die eben gewöhnlicher
sandstein zum beispiel sicher heißt zum
beispiel hat er nämlich so häufig auch
nicht aber der hat eine ganz klare
struktur kristall später nicht
willkürlich der später nach einem
inneren organisationsprinzip das heißt
man könnte sagen der stein an stein der
ist in sich noch nicht richtig gebildet
aber in kristall schon ihr die kristalle
feste form
die ist nicht willkürlich kristalle
differenzieren sind an bestimmten
geometrischen muster aus
natürlich sagen sandstein besteht am
ende auch im ganz krass teilen das sehr
genau anschauen aber in jedem fall sense
und sandstrände handhaben es ist was
anderes
wir werden sie so ein kristall jetzt
leuchtet ist einfach nicht also wir euch
das ein auf anhieb so interessant ist
einfach differenziert hatte ist
ausgebildete an der fau und mehr
struktur als ein bloßer hand statt bloß
ich weiß nicht was diese stadt wo geht
es standen auch mich an kristallen aber
jetzt warum metall morgen mitteilte
das könnte der grund sein das metall
noch über dem kristalle
hinsichtlich der komplexität an sorgen
[Musik]
das weiß noch gut die leute
wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerade ein
paar traurige vorzunehmen stellen ist
daran
richtig alles ist ein guter punkt man
könnte sagen stein kann man für schlecht
verformen man kann ihn vielleicht
meißeln aber er ist nicht so
dynamischer form gewesen getan ist im
moment springt man kann sie auch steine
schmelzen
sie springen häufig wo manch manche
kommen mit meiner mutter kultur
sie wissen dass von
meteoriteneinschlägen ja da schmilzt das
schreiben auch unter bestimmen also es
wäre die möglichkeit mir fällt jetzt
momentan nichts besseres ein was hat er
noch zu den metallen sowohl von diesen
zu pflanzen schöpfung
okay das leuchtet ein also dann kommt
hier die pflanze und das wäre praktisch
wir mit würden was beginnen
im gegensatz zum amerikanischen rahmen
des organischen pflanze
sortieren das ist klar
von diesem zu menschen
das ist praktisch die entwicklung mit
zwanziger szene dieser app ich gebe ein
seminar über die täglichen wenn sie mit
tiermedizin oder mit mediziner sprechen
so mehr tut als wenn sie sagen hier
zwischen mensch und tier besteht ein
qualitativer unterschied so wie zum
beispiel zwischen steinen passt dass
dort mit der neuen gibson qualitativen
unterschied
wir würden die mediziner sagen
wissenschaftler für zahn den menschen
ist doch auch nur ein tier
es gibt männliche tiere und nicht mehr
richtig
wir sind homo sapiens was sagen sie dazu
warum ist das überzeugen durch das tier
von menschen unterscheiden so als sei
der mensch kann tieren die biologen sage
folgendes sagen dass du sagen
anders als er deshalb diskutieren über
begriff und der mensch ist ein tiere und
der apfel cynthia und so weiter und so
fort es gibt ganz viele andere tiere
also hier ist
nach der heutigen biologie ist ihren
oberbegriff legato und da fallen da
steht mir einzelne arten tod ist jetzt
aber nicht ganz so denkt natürlich dass
die hier definition kann ich heute auch
interviews ist dass die garten gießen an
dem nicht ihren bekannten bietet sich
dem tier begriff zu nehmen er sagt zwar
es ist eine anlage zur tierhaltung ist
nicht die höchste anzahl der mensch hat
irgendwas tierisches an sich aber er hat
noch etwas höher gesetzlich und es wäre
schon unser selbstbewusstsein oder sein
vermögen der moralität werden umfrage
unter ihn einmal mehr die erste meinung
dass herr gerecht und her da steht nur
einen ganz großen tradition
man nennt das wollte ja auch anthropozän
tristan dass der mensch im zentrum steht
der van ist der meinung sie werden ja
nicht aufgenommen man sieht sie nicht
werden
wer ist der meinung dass man diesen
unterschied zu tun kann so machen kann
die hertha zwischen mensch und tier
unterscheiden kann
wer ist dieser versuch
und wer ist der meinung dass man es so
sehen sollte gut als ich jeder vergeben
hat seine guten gründen das kann ich
jetzt wirklich sagt und hier gibt es
eine riesen debatte darum auch in der
gegenwärtigen philosophie das ist keine
vergangene diskussion sind die debatte
ist total lebendig ob wir nur
quantitativ von anderen tieren
verschieden sind also bei mir ein
bisschen intelligenter situation wieder
ein bisschen komplexer sind bereits
dessen gradueller unterschied
das kann ich hier entscheiden gerade
hell als quartett auch quantitativ ist
es größere hirnrinde usw
oder ist es qualitativ qualitativ bzw
kategorisch
jetzt eine riesige wand schauen sie sich
die zusammenfassung man das seminar über
tätig an werden sie es interessiert
damals bin ich ein
das gibt die gerade bei listen und die
die funktion ist zunehmend es also
gerade listen sie die die sagen der
mensch ist nur ein tier der besonderen
art und die die anderen vertreter
differenzial listen zeigen
der mensch ist stand der kategorische
hier vom tisch ja ist denn da heute noch
so viel in dieser krise weil die tiere
vor stunden hat der einem letzten 20 30
jahren um die order im sport schönen
markt und den augen geöffnet und wenn
man unter diesen bericht zum beispiel
was sie gelernt haben sich eine narbe
tätigen wenn man hört was den weg dazu
sagen muss man zu dem ergebnis kommen
dass amerikaner in folge
also sehen dass heute auch die meist
aber die charta das eben sehr polemisch
daran stellte card hat diese vertrieben
das wir tiere nicht von maschinen
unterschreibt und es ist natürlich nicht
ganz fertig descartes hätte jobs weg
nach descartes wäre das tier hier
eigentlich ansässigen im nordbadischen
er sagt wir können ein tier nichts nach
der maschine
mit guten gründen unterscheiden konnte
so etwas wie die maschine und wenn wir
ihn stoßen und einen laut von sich gibt
ist es so wenn wir eine drehorgel
spielen und ein laut produziert das ist
eine extreme position des wagens für
dich zu recht aber es gibt auch noch
anhält diese qualitativen differenz hier
ist zb die karts richtig aber es gibt
auch noch differenziertere anreger die
sagen auch tieres also nichtmenschliche
tiere
tiere sind lebewesen heillosen maschinen
der sdk aber dennoch und ihre lebewesen
sind wir auch gibt es einen qualitativen
unterschied in der art des lebens also
man muss natürlich unbedingt die
katholische position übernehmen um einen
kategorischen unterschied zwischen
mensch und tier begründen sie in der
gegenwärtigen debatte gibt es eine
position die heißt animismus animalis
muss und da gibt es ein hauptvertreter
der heißt er mit bodo sondern und der
sagt geben wir sind vier personen
passieren wir sind wesentlich tiere wir
sind grundlegend tieren übrigens eine
andere vertreterin der debatte dass die
linke und die sagt nein wir sind zwar
durch um zum tierischen organismus
konstituiert aber wir sind damit nicht
dem tisch sind was uns besonders ist
unser selbstbewusstsein ist die
konstruktionsdaten situation sehen sie
schreit immer besser es wird immer
besser findet sie nicht sofort stellen
bildung hier sondern weg hier
jetzt interessiert kann ich ihnen einige
links schicke ich habe mal ein seminar
über dieses thema gemacht
es ist eine riesen debatte und als zb
wenn wir eben uns dem animalis muss
anschließend wird dann wären wir im
grunde nichts anderes als
damit auch immer tieres sind wir auch
schon oder gegen sperrt sich etwas in
unserer situation häufig viele von uns
mit sagen ja wir sind zwar lebendig aber
wir sind etwas ganz besonders lebendiges
weil er fahrerisch zurecht blau sind und
so weiter aber es gibt der rabatte
vertreten ist die debatte ist zu garten
es sprechen vielleicht die meisten
gründe doch tatsächlich für den animalis
muss momentan für regen moment da zahlt
jeder mensch und menschenaffen habe man
aus der ständig meines erachtens die
fragen zur gänze nicht zwischen menschen
und tieren sondern zwischen der
entwicklung und forderung von tier und
mensch muss eigentlich habe er deshalb
das hast du deine plans mensch im
vergleich zu
ja das ist sehr guter punkt und da gibt
es ein buch von einem thomas einem
gewissen thomas middelhoff und das heißt
also die kluft und das ist gerade frage
was unterscheidet meinen schaefer und
seinem nächsten verwandten mix stil
verband und die these dieses buches von
gap ist das wird das deswegen eine
qualitative differenz zwischen uns und
demnächst verwandten tieren besteht weil
der homo sapiens erlaubt sein
entwicklungsgeschichte seinen nächsten
verwandten umgebracht hat ausgelotet hat
denken sie an den neandertalern und
denkt es wiederum weit über jens
zensieren homo rudolfensis uns aber es
gibt ganz viele menschen nämlich
hominiden die dem homo sapiens sehe mich
aber es gibt eine theorie die besagt
homo sapiens hat seinem nächsten
verwandten im laufe der evolution
umgebracht wurden oder die sind selbst
ausgestochen und dadurch dass diese
zwischen glieder zwischen mensch und
affe ausgestorben sind die hier ist der
mensch sterben muß ab jetzt eben jetzt
qualitative von seinen texten
mitgliedern
die zürcher treten ab diese theorie wenn
sie ausgestorben phase des spiels nach
und nun müssen wir dann schon irgendwie
immer der definition der die menschen
auch auf die idee ausgesprochen sie
ausgerottet
ja aber müsste dann eben hier auf diese
anderen formen menschlichen lebens vom
eingeben das ist das stimmt und die gibt
es jetzt aber eben nicht wir wissen eben
auch nicht genau wie die gedacht haben
wir könnten rückschlüsse ziehen wenn sie
zb einige instrumente ich glaube auch
den neandertaler hat man jetzt
herausgefunden hat so eine gewisse
religiosität bekannt eine gewisse
tendenz bewusstsein gehabt und da würde
man sagen gut an der anderter ist
vielleicht auch hier auf diese menschen
seite bezug nehmen
aber irgendwo an einem bestimmten punkt
muss man sagen hier wird es dann doch
sehr sehr nicht menschlich mehr zum
beispiel kein transzendenz bewusstsein
auftritt wenn keine wirkliche
begriffliche artikulation keine
wirkliche sprache mehr vorhanden ist
dann müssen wir die anthropologen frage
aber es wird die diskussion
[Musik]
dies ist trotzdem nicht aus kann die
politik bus zu warten da ist nicht die
erste biologisch
die motive des bewusstseins zeit
eigentlich übersetzten und wirst deinen
vergleichen
genau als es salaam sagen völlig zu
recht die größe allein ist nicht im
schreiben des gehirns gekonnt auf die
komplexität
es kommt auf die packung der neue
wohnung an wie dich die ducati dichter
gepackt sind die mehr verbindungen
zwischen immer bestehen desto komplexer
die fähigkeiten des gehirns denken usw
und er muss 100 rinder betrachten die
hirnrinde muss besonders ausgeprägt zeit
voran der präfrontale kortex das
evolutionär jüngst gebiet des gehirns da
sind die komplexesten dinge enthalten
als sie sehr spannende frage sich sehen
das thema ist aktuell darüber reden
aktuelle biologin biologen und verlosung
finden sagt also die form der
organisation also müssen angst sagt dass
hier hier oben was ich geschrieben habe
ist die form form der organisation
da ich denke besser trifft hier
vielleicht zu komplexität das ist die
form der organisation hinzu vom stein
beginnen und bis hin zum endstand mit
ihr auch die kräfte umtriebe des
geschäfts viel artiger werden und sich
endlich alle in der gestalt des menschen
sofern dieses sie fassen konnte verein
bei den menschen verstanden die reihe
stellen wir kennen kein geschäft über
ihm das fertige und künstliche
organisiert zeit erscheint das höchste
wozu eine herrensitzung gebildet werden
können das ganz klar an
centris muss der mensch im zentrum und
das auch seine gipfel punkte endlich
menschen als krone der schöpfung ist ein
traum wahr so weiter durch diese reihe
von wesen mehr so weit ist einzelne
bestimmung des geschehens zuließen eine
herrschende tätlichkeit der haupt form
der freunde unzählbare preis ab wechseln
sich immer mehr der menschengestalt naht
in der ungebildeten tief im reich der
pflanzen und pflanzen tiere war sie nach
oben kämpfen dem organismus für kommen
erwiesen war sie deutlicher die anzahl
der garten warten
sie verloren vereinigte sich zuletzt in
entspann sich jetzt
die frage könnte man sich überlegen
bild sind ja keine platz was die
bakterien einzel
gute frage haben als jedenfalls ist es
etwas was unterhalb der tiere steht die
harfe beiden etwas hat gemacht
sie müssen bedenken dass wartezeiten die
biologie noch in den kinderschuhen
steckt wir kommen nach der anderen auf
210 zu sprechen
die apps chinesen um die pre formation
steam die frage wie sich die natur
findet also wieder konzentrieren also
tiere die serie mit ganzen gemeinsamer
man könnte vielleicht hier auch an
qualen denken oder an
sie sterben in solchen chorale sind ja
auch so in grenzen
sind ihre pflanzen allerdings im fleisch
fressende grenzen hat die erinnern uns
an seinen mund zu schieben
aber was ist jetzt die these
hinsichtlich dass diese ganze
entwicklung ja nichts
das thema natur
[Musik]
naja wenn es entscheidend ist hier diese
haupt vor also alle teil etwas gemeinsam
zu
trotz dieser differenz die wir haben
haben alle etwas gemeinsam als eine
kunst die arbeit an bier ist ist die
haufe die armenier ist im menschen
wirklich deutlich wird also man kann es
auch so sagen da ist eine form ganz gut
immer deutlicher wird die am anfang
recht nun deutlich wissen
er sagt hier auch chancen hier seien in
der ungebildete tief gut gewählt also
eine form die immer klarer immer
gebildet hat immer deutlich
sie würden so verstellen der mensch ist
es ganz deutlich die deutsche form alles
davor ist noch unklar
die form klärt sich zu menschen auf
diese von dieser arbeiter
wie die gestalten das haben wir auch die
kräfte und triebe sich nie mehr von der
awo und fortpflanzung der gewächse stieg
der trieb zum kunstwerk der insekten zu
hals und mutter sorgte vögel und land
ihre endlich gab zu menschen ähnlichen
gedanken und zur eigenen selbst
erworbenen fähigkeiten die sich zuletzt
alles mit der von unfähigkeit freiheit
und humanität dass menschen vereint also
er sagt jetzt hier kommt es wieder ins
spiel kräfte betriebe müsse besonders
darauf achten also wie die form und
gestalt sich den menschen lehrt das
könnte mit formen braucht im einzel
das könnt ihr mit dieser hauch von
gemeint sein
hast du die haufen es sollte im endspiel
paradigmatischen form besitzt
genau
ganz genau so ich denke so muss man sich
so vorstellen also der mensch muss ich
das glaube ich auch wieder alles wird
das tut mir leid
es brauche ich nämlich wieder hier die
nationale frage zu beginn stellen ja
warum
[Musik]
in den hallen zu tun haben sonja der
trieb ist sein deswegen habe ich ihn
kreist um die macht der trieb ist die
grundlage der ist die basis als er trieb
es nicht auf derselben ebene in die
stammgäste sind er ist die basis dieser
entwicklung die hertha die form der
organisation der trieb ist nicht auf
derselben gestalten sind direkt dieser
entwicklung zugrunde
ohne trieb können des steins zahlen
metall pflanzen so werde nicht bild wir
brauchen den trainer als eine basis zu
so muss an dieser stelle und da sagte er
auf einige sitzt dazu und jetzt würde
ich das ganze mal so schön es ist leider
so dass wieder bestätigt aber es ist ja
video alles enthalten nämlich jetzt so
gleichweit stift auswählen
[Musik]
also haben wir diese völlig richtig
glauben aus muss mir das vorstellen eine
versteht versteht das so wir haben
deutlich hier so eine form
ja die extremitäten heute aufrecht ich
dann könnte man aus interpretieren das
klo die das auf allen vieren den
menschen erhebt sich auch eine
vorrichtung transzendenz stichworte
erhebt sich der aufrechte gang ist ein
kennzeichnung der menschen die tiere der
hominiden aufrichtig denken sie auch
immer die evolution entwicklung der hand
im detail
man kann diese form der in allen
verschiedenen tarnung nachvollziehen
denken sie mal die menschliche hand
abonnierbare daumen dass sie überhaupt
dass die zeigefinger und daumen einander
verliert sie können alle fälle vier
finger mit dem daumen zusammengreifen
das ist die bedingung dafür dass wir
auch werkzeugbau und von ihr beide
daumen ist ein ganz wichtiges
evolutionäres merkmals menschen und
könntest du sagen ja für alle sondern
auch rechtlich angehabt
weniger ja gut yahoo.de auch aufrecht
richtig aber er konnte nicht die die als
er hat natürlich auch klar
ich konnte natürlich nicht er hatte kein
daumen man konnte nichts mehr trainieren
konnten fans war das werkzeug aber
aufrecht ist ja schon richtig was
richtig also zu sehen ist es durchaus
eine starke these aber ich denke schon
an der entwicklung von der kralle zur
hand also wenn sich hier so die kralle
haben sowas hin zur hand das ist sowas
sagen
12345 ja
da kann sie sehen da ist schon es ist
schon ein fortschritt man könnte jetzt
natürlich sagen nein ist es kein
fortschritt
die hand es doch keinen verteidigungs
oder angriffswerkzeuge ich kann jetzt
noch mal die fingernägel wachsen lassen
aber es ist ihr eine verzögerung der
kranke unsere nägel waren einst mal mit
sicherheit niemals zu befragen
anthropologen die die ferien haben oder
sind relikte eines einstigen einzigen
verteidigungswaffen ca
das ist um die degeneration könnte oder
wie sie es für den granit zu haben jetzt
nicht die generation soll es das nicht
fortbildung
[Musik]
ja bereichen sprachen wir dass der
osteologie stehen die serie um dann habe
ich dabei
[Musik]
richtig das entscheidende ist aber der
abonnierbare daumen dass wir eben unsere
ganzen film zeigefinger mittelfinger
kleine finger mit dem daumen samt ring
das könne nacht nicht und deswegen
können sie auch nicht so diffizilen
fertigkeiten ausbilden und den begriff
des begreifens greifen kann ich nur
etwas gut wenn ich eine komplexe hand
hat mit dem andauern und es begreifen
ist natürlich auch geistig zu verstehen
erkennen
das heißt mit unserer komplexeren hans
tour mit unseren komplexen ergreifen und
begriff im musikalischen sinn hat sich
ausgebreitet dass keiner gezeigt dass
körperliche vorn entwickeln auch die
geistige fortentwickeln witzig ist da
war einiges
revolution
jetzt folgt das ist alles eine frage des
zufalls demonstration hier das alles
also sechs spielen 2016 sie der hand mit
daumen überhaupt mitmachen können ja
gewinn chance gewesen
um heute ist es so dass die menschen in
einer welt leben in den zweckmäßigen
seinen daumen zu haben
und wenn wir in den bereichen 50 jahren
wird wenn sie mobil sein dass frauen
nicht überwacht werden könnte könnte
sein 17 sie machen auf mich auf den
wichtigen punkt aufmerksam nämlich
fragen gibt es die notwendigkeit diese
entwicklung erscheint eine teleologische
viel früher schon mal eine triologie
voraussetzen theologie deshalb wissen
sie was triologie heißt also telos
genauso der zielgerichtet
und die kann man natürlich mit guten
gründen bestreiten es gibt keine
richtung auf den menschen hinter
menschen durch zufallsprodukt wenn der
komet eingeschlagen wäre da dann werde
menschenrechte stand in südamerika
während weiterhin dinosaurier sind halt
zu finden genauso theologie dass die
zähigkeit und genau so dass diese
differenz zwischen notwendigkeit die
schalter hertha hier anzusetzen wäre das
kontingent oder auch kontinents und auch
zufall ist nicht dasselbe kontingents
aber kontingents heißt nicht notwendig
möglich aber nicht geöffnet kontingents
zufolge sogar mehr beliebigkeit
ja es gibt keine gesetzmäßigkeit die
dazu führen musste dass die menschen in
der außen- oder man könnte sagen der
menschen ist gar nicht das höchste
lebewesen gibt auch nicht wenn man sie
wieder einen übergang von der kralle zur
hand jetzt kann ich ziemlich schlecht
verteidigen da musste diese rückbildung
auch kompensieren durch geistige
fähigkeiten der menschen müsse stark und
sind wir kraft sich zu verteidigen
müsste er sich dinge einfach musste
clever was müsst ihr den pokal
einstellen musste kooperieren um
überleben zu als die kompensation zu
entwicklung ist steht im interconti
tiere des mängelwesen system entnehmen
gewesen ist natürlich gesehen und diese
menge kompensieren muss durch geist und
die worte der verein bei allen denkens
er brauche der box einen großen einfluss
gewissermaßen zum spiel schreibt das
sagen seine texte über die am forstweg
hat und letztendlich wäre bestimmt war
das gefühl und ja also ich denke es kann
jetzt noch differenzieren
das ganze ist ganz wichtig um
theologische politischen kontext vor ort
um diesem theologischen kontext schließt
nicht aus dass die menschen aus freiheit
sich bewegt also theologischer kontext
und freiheit muss ich nicht
notwendigerweise widersprechen es gibt
natürlich technologische ansichten wie
von speedo sagt alles ganz gerade
terminiert ist aufgrund des theologische
texte skylifter sieht gar nichts wieder
versuche auch die bibel sagt
letztendlich vor dem hintergrund der
herder schreibt dass der streit ist also
der bibel ist der menschen
verantwortlich dass sein team auch wenn
natürlich der ein geschäft ist geschäft
seien frei sein ist kein notwendiger
widerspruch
aber es eine riesen debatte der
philosophien vor allem regierung gibt ok
und jetzt haben wir hier als letzte
fertigkeiten für untätigkeit freiheit
und humanität da sehen sie zu der
freiheit trotz biologischen kontext ist
sagte sie hier ist natürlich noch
genauer schauen was wir freiheit
bedeutet
vor ort was ziemlich guten gelassen
vorher fremd sind der kreativität tun
können was man will sich eigenen zwecke
zu setzen
mittels der künftig kann ja aber was
verstehen sie unter humanität als
formalität
so kommt ist
ja gut wenn es gegen die richtige
richtung humanität was würden sie sagen
alltag begegnet sie humanität
was ist ein beispiel von humanität oder
inhumanität ergebnis genau diese
teilweise auf nächstenliebe
menschlichkeit barmherzigkeit mit leider
diese ganzen funken dem man könnte auch
sagen moralität sind also hier wird der
biologische begriff des menschen zum
normativen bickel alle zum inbegriff des
wertes der moralität die für die
menschenrettung die die menschen
aufrecht
als ich ist eine moralische entwicklung
angeht also härter wird es sagen diese
fortentwicklung dieser entwicklung ist
nicht nur eine aufklärung der form ist
nicht nur eine zielgerichtete auf dem
zweck hinziehen sind sie ist auch ein
wert unter dem wert verbunden der in der
realisierten sie konnten normativ die
mission spielern
würde es dudelsack und mainz haben zu
recht darauf hingewiesen man findet so
was wie fürsorge für andere art und
gliedert auch mitglieder einer anderen
art auch die tierhalter nichtmenschliche
tiere
die frage ist nur die ob das dann nicht
beck nichtmenschlichen tieren den stil
gebunden ist oder ob es tatsächlich ein
moralisches prinzip steht nachdem dieses
tier handelt oder ob es den tieren ein
gebot ist mitleid zu empfinden sie
kennen die beiden spiele haben das
wasser also wir können uns auf
konzernstrukturen andere sehr schnell
versetzt denn anfang entstand gesicht
verzieht aus schmerz wenn leiden wir
diesen schmerz partien mit wenn man sie
gern dass uns wieder spielen
sowas könnten auch tieren gehabt aber er
wird das sagen hier geht es im spiegel
chinesen prinzipiell geht es um
moralische überzeugung nach dem
viehhandel moralischer gesetze und sowas
besitzen nicht menschlich hier
sicherlich nicht aber vielleicht so
etwas wie mitleid register
da ist er also ganz gehandelt prozent
rasant ihre besitzen das nicht das kann
man mit guten gründen fragt
man erzählt aus überzeugung entsteht
oder weil die natur mensch mal so
geschaffen haben
die gute frage
ich glaube dass dieser widerspruch sich
verheddern nicht stellt weil er sagen
würde die natur führt gerade dazu dass
der mensch überzeugen ausbilden
manchester hat eine solchen stellen
diesen prozess dass da eben gerade
überzeugung ins spiel kommen also hat er
würde diese position zwischen natur und
vernunft die wir folgen angemalt haben
nicht unterscheiden er durch seine natur
und vernunft sind natur entwickelt sich
nach vernünftigen prinzipien
das können wir eben wie wir gesehen
haben durchaus guten gründen infrage
stellen wir wollen ja immer kritisch
sagt nicht alles wortwörtlich tja also
jetzt eingesetzt gibt es zweck in der
natur das könne so ein bisschen zu
springen
hier sind ganz interessante begriffs
wendungen
er spricht von einem vorrat haus des
lebendigen szenen sind ist eine gewisse
bekommen
die natur sorgt dafür dass alles sein
rechts und zweck hat die dazu rechnet
chancen aus das einverständnis die natur
rechnet die rechnet für die erhaltung
des ganzen geschlechtsteile ökonomie der
natur als ein sehr harmonisches versteht
sich
nur für die organisierte ein geschäft
ist desto mehr ist seit bauer
zusammengesetzt aus den niedrigen reich
damit sind diese unter reformen gemacht
unter der erde fängt diese
vielseitigkeit an und sie wächst hinauf
durch pflanzen tiere bis zu vier
artisten geschäft den menschen sein blut
und seine finger weh gestand teile sind
ein kompendium der welt kalt und er das
salz und säuren öl und wasser kräfte der
vegetation der walze der empfindung sind
in ihm organisch vereint ineinander
verweben
verstehen sie das
also wir gehen wieder zurück hier haben
wir wieder ein bisschen die tafel klar
also wie stellen sie sich das vor dieses
verwebt sein
ich liebe dich das vor
mit den menschen und die haben alle was
mir noch er spricht nur von säuren salze
fassung salze
was die vier prozent besteht welche
mittel prozent bestellte menschen das
wasser
ja sehr wie sehr viel gibt noch die
knochen aber sonst nicht viel knochen
bisschen heiße bisschen gold glaube ich
sogar irgendwie ist es sprudelt noch
also ganz minimal senkt auch noch ganz
minimal zu
aber was er ist es überwiegen elemente
aus dem der mensch besteht das salz
natürlich auch wir schwitzen ja wir
müssen uns vorstellen dieses verhältnis
der mensch ist der mir zusammengesetzt
aus diesen niederer wie es nicht element
der kristalle sind kristalle aller deckt
das kristall ist im menschen enthalten
ist die frage wie vereint der mensch das
unter sich ist es so dass wir sagen
können wenn im ölsäure plus salzwasser
und dann kommt der menschen zumutbar
als es ist kein atp fürs modell schätzen
sie mal 60 kilo wasser 60 liter 60 liter
wasser ein bisschen zahlen so ein
bisschen öl zusammen aus allen elementen
aus dem der mensch besteht und würde das
mal und konnte mensch dabei raus
wir sind hier wir sind ja da wird ja
aufgenommen würde ich ja also man könnte
manchmal denken dass man die menschen
tatsächlich so zusammengesetzt sind
aber er war auch jemand wütend ist dann
denkt man das ist so beschaffen ist ja
aber sie sagt zu recht es ist die
organisation halte sehe es geht hier
ganz klar um die form die form dieser
elemente organisation
das ist entscheidend dass dagegen werden
debatte sagt man es geht additives
modell das ist also dieses unteren
modell des praktischen additives modell
das vertreibt werde eben gerade nicht
und gibt es transformative mutter ganz
tiefes vertritt er das könnte auf die
form und die diese verschiedenen
elemente zusammen bilden
ok also organisch vereint in ihm
verübelt nicht bloßen ist somit nicht
bloß im topf und das ist nicht der oscar
kommt nicht der mensch das ist okay es
gibt es spricht hier von einer
organischen gemacht
zu einem von organisierten vom stifter
hier spricht die auch von mosel die
niedrigste geschöpft wird das sind böse
und schwärmen von der produktion und
kräfte als der niedrigste geschäften
finden sich elemente kräfte sein
er spricht von einem eine masse um
nämlich wieder zusammen trägt trägt
gedrängter kräfte ein zusammenhang
spielt obersten haushalte natur ist für
komisch zu verstehen und natur
die bietet all das was das leben auch in
der mitte sind sehr harmonisches
verständnis ich glaube das können wir
auch ein bisschen an zu springen
ich möchte mich jetzt noch fest sie
finden die folien im internet und auch
jetzt konnte im zweiten kapitel aufholen
lässt sprechen keine kraft der natur ist
ohne organ das organ ist aber nie die
kraft selbst die mittels jedem brücke wo
wir eine kraft wirken sehen wirkt sich
allerdings einem organ diesem harmonisch
ball dasselbe wird sie unseren sinnen
wenigstens nicht sich mit ihm aber es
zählt zugleich da und wenn wir der
durchgehend in analogie der natur
kinderaugen dürfen sie hat sich selbst
hat sie sich das leben zu gebildet also
spricht einmal analogie der natur was
genau kann er damit sei gemeint
logitech
als die natur ist nach derselben logik
gebildet und die luke ist immer wichtig
der haupt form des menschen reformierte
kai mit seiner schöpfung bereit lagen
halt gesehen reformiert also vorgeformte
kann keine gesehen was wir vom ersten
gibt es während eines geschützten mehr
aggressiv wirkende organische kräfte hat
ein einziges wesen dieser hinsicht so
erzeugt es selbst sind die geschlechter
geteilt und muss jedes derselben
organisation des abkömmlings beitrag und
zwar nach der verschiedenheit des baus
auf eine verschiedene weise geschildert
und pflanzt motor der begriff heimat ich
aber dass du ihn gewirkt haben nur einen
leisen haupt er berührte er selbst
erzeugt zu beleben auch in tieren oder
lebendige bereits ein cs leben durch
alle kinder her sprechen fast alles
produktions und reporter für uns kraft
ist darf die frucht der belegen oft nur
aus unterreit die verschiedene viel
artiger deckt der organisation nach die
tische bewerb desto gründlicher wird das
was aber jedem den kein und nannte hier
ist organischer materie zu der lebendige
kräfte kommen müssen sie erst zu gestalt
des künftigen geschäfte zu finden also
lebendige kräfte da sehen sie ist hier
konnte
das ist alles noch nichts mehr
zusammenhängend und jetzt kommt
entscheidet körper ganz entscheidende
begriff behandeln müssen welche
auswirkungen gehen immer des vogels fuhr
die frucht gestaltet wird und sich diese
von ende die organischer kraft muss
zurück in dem sie ordnet sie zieht teil
sang und treiben sie auseinander ja es
scheint als ob mehrere kräfte im
wettstreit wehren und zuerst eine
missgeburt kühlten wollten bis sie ihr
gleichgewicht treten um das geschäft das
wird was ist seiner gattin auch samsung
sieht man diese wandlungen diese
lebendigen wirken sowohl im high des
vogels als im unterleib des tieres das
gebinde die mediation wird mich spricht
man eigentlich wenn man von keimen die
duh entwickelt werden oder von einer ep
genesis redet nach der die glieder von
außen zu fix jetzt ist sie ein ganz
wichtiger begriff der die genesis
chancen in der pds spd
da steckt natürlich das griechische wort
geldes ist dass es die schöpfung und
happy baby heißt auf daraufhin also
darauf dass sie drei hin zu wachsen
das sind so geschickt dass hinzu kommen
also und das ist die begründung für
seine entwicklung war die rede von hause
zurück wenn sie solche begriffe nicht
gleich verstehen
dann schauen sie einfach mal hier nach
wikipedia später dürfen sind natürlich
nicht zitieren daraus arbeit sondern wie
die täter können sie nur verwenden um
sich ein bisschen zu informieren ganz
schnellen kanal sowie peter bitte nicht
im hause deutet er wird zuerst
internation als ep genese der beginn ist
eine bezeichnung für die herausbildung
neuer strukturen aus ungefähr materie
bei der entwicklung eines lebe die ist
es die wurde im 18 jahrhundert verfasste
friedrich wolf der auseinandersetzung
wieder damals herrschten reformations
lehrer eingeführt
also wir haben jetzt hier die opposition
die genesis wäre das reformation statt
dass man bitte hier hin
das eine wichtige unterscheidung und
jetzt noch ein bisschen genauer noch
schauen was es damit auf sich habe
also kamen hier
hieß es
reformation
so geht's
wissen sie welche theorie jetzt hierher
dafür tritt der pianist oder
präsentation mit diesem zu tun hatte
nach diesem zitat hier ja
ja genau also man spricht zeigt denn nun
eigentlich wenn man von keimen den
etiketten oder von einer epidemie system
pss wäre nicht die wirklich nicht die
eigenen sind gezahlt eigentlich vertrete
eine pre formations these und es gibt
hier noch präsentations lehrerinnen
sowie die täterschaft dieb reformations
lehre präventions- theorien von
lateinisch prämie form und formation die
gestaltung bildung ist ein entwicklungs
biologische these die antiken von dem
kriegsschiff philosophen max ahlers
vertreten wurde und der neuzeit im 17
jahrhundert wieder auftrat und dann bis
1900 hinein fort eine weitere damals
gebräuchlichen bezeichnungen
evolutionslehre revolutionen sinne von
entwicklung als reiner wachstumsprozess
weil die ganz andere bedeutung hatte
also reformisten nahmen an dass der
gesamte organismus in berlin an dem
buddhismus bzw im alkoholismus
vorgebildet reformiert sein und sich nur
noch entfalten wachsen ist erinnert sich
an die haupt vorher sagen wir so es gibt
diese hauptformen dies schon angelegt
und die kopfhörer menschen vollkommen
zur geltung
dem stand die theorie der pekinese gegen
als ich die strukturen organe eines
organismus ersten lauf der individuelle
genese war seit der antike und wissen
dass 17
die herrschende meinung gewesen wurde
dann aber im zuge der aufklärung als
nicht mehr plausibel durch prüfung des
tisches 15 abgängen ist und härter ist
auf der ersten sohle der auftrag erst im
frühen 19 jahrhundert konnte sich erneut
bis heute als gültigen geschenkt habt
ihr als auch die evolutionstheorie ist
eine epigenetische tendenziell
epigenetische typen keine preforms es
entwickelt sich nicht so dass da ein
grund ist die immer komplexer wird
sondern kommt einfach immer wieder was
dazu bildung sagte jetzt ging es ist
eine wirkung ihrer kräfte dem die natur
eine masse vorbereitet hatte die natur
hat dieser bildung eine masse
vorbereitet dass es ein ökonomisches
verständnis die natur sorgt dafür dass
da eine bildung stattfinden kann
dieses die natur dies bestätigen die
perioden der bildung in verschiedenen
gattungen von mehr oder minder
organischer vielseitigkeit und fülle von
lebens griff nur hier aus lassen sich
die missbildungen geschützt durch
krankheit zufall oder durch die
vermischung verschiedener gattung
erklären und es ist dieser weg der
einzige den uns im alb ihren werken die
kraft und lebensweise betont dass eine
fortgehen tanna
gleichsam auftritt als angehender mal
hierhin als epic games ist
beginn ist es ist das tier
fortschreitende
entwicklung
und das hinzutreten oder faulen neuer
nicht angelegter nicht ja nicht angelegt
hatten
cloud von außen
aber nicht dass es schon angelegt ist
als konstrukteur reformationszeit
einfach die form ist bereits angelegt
und entwickelt sich das
dann ganz da die evolutionstheorie wäre
themen 10 happy genesen reformation so
stellte man sich das früher vor spam
oder auch immer immer ist das schon so
ein kleines männchen der war das wasser
durch den samen und die idee gebärmutter
der frau jetzt schon so kleines männchen
oder weibchen das wird noch größer wenn
sie hingegen die im fall x entwicklung
anschauen sehen sie dass es hoch
differenziert das ist die eine
grundstruktur da kommt dann plötzlich
werden dinge hinzu das ist informationen
der mensch steht am anfang ist eine
entwicklung nicht zu aus der befruchtete
eizelle sich zu wort
ich denke es ihr so zu verstehen dass
jede natürliche art geht es natürlich
gewesen beginnt geben als dieses wesen
vor gefolgt als er ist praktisch die
ganze forschen minimal zu müssen sie bis
[Musik]
soweit das nicht als jetzt nicht im
sinne der gestrige termin ist zusätzlich
durch das schöpfen und theologisches
oder so platonisch muskat und ist es so
dass ist ideen gibt ideen dass die uhr
bilder dass verschiedene bilder gibt die
gab es von vorne oder biologischen
kontext und dem steht eben endg ist der
auffassung dass sich die form erst noch
entwickelt haben können verschiedene
richtung das thema was hinzukommt wurde
auch dass zum beispiel der mensch durch
äußere umstände wie andere formen des
siam letztes von tierte beispiel
gebracht dass der mensch zum kontakt mit
medien nutzung der technik dass dessen
hände sich zurück entwickeln so was
während der reformationszeit wenig
möglich also mit reformations theorie
könnten nicht erklären wie praktisch
äußere umstände zur änderung der form
weiter also wie eben auch die form
reagierte auf äußerungen stimmung sowas
kann ihnen den reformationstag sehr
schlecht erklären
während der apps ist epigenomics für
flexibles von neue umstände
also ich bestimmt jetzt zum zwanzigsten
jahrhundert steht man der zweiten hälfte
des 14
als die reformations theorie ist eine
sache der aufklärung
das ist eine sache der aufgenommenen
schon platon könnte man sagen
durch die idee leere aber das eigentlich
in der theorie der aufklärung aufklärung
weil die aufklärung selbst staat indiana
hat den auftritt klare prinzipien die
sich aufklären und ein prinzip ist eben
eine form die dem zugrunde die auch
vernünftig fassbar ist auf dem hat immer
sehr viel mit vernunft zu tun und es
bringt viel unklarheit drei viele
ungewissheiten die sich gar nicht so
klar antizipieren lassen all das ist
wichtig und jetzt eben hier bildung
bildung ein wichtiger begriff wird
bildung ist eine wirkung von kräften die
mit einer masse erarbeitet
und jetzt konzentrierten punkt alle
zusammen der kräfte und formen ist wie
der rückgang noch stillstand zum
fortschreiten allem theologisches bild
ganz klar die natur entwickelt sich vor
ort das war dieses gilt weiß werden wo
der mensch ganz oben steht der komischen
fassen
das erste geschäft das ans licht tritt
unter dem strahl der sommer sich als
eine königin des unterirdischen reiches
zeit bis die pflanzen
was sind ihre bestandteile salz und
eisen schwefel und was sonst an fahnen
kräften das unterirdische zu ihr hinauf
zu läutern vermehrt hinauf zu läuten
das heißt diese bestand hat ist materie
markiert materiellen bestandteile werden
geläut hat sie werden transformiert sie
werden höher entwickelt sie haben
veredelte könnte begeistern könnte
materie diese ganz primitive bestattet
werden vergeistigt sublimiert und daraus
entsteht dann die pflanze wie kamen sie
zu diesen teilen durch innere
organischer kraft durch welches
wirtschaft beihilfe der elemente in jene
sich zu eigen zu machen streben schauen
sie widerstrebe ganz klar strebe hier
kriegen und was tut sie mit ihren sitzen
sie an sich diese bestandteile
verarbeitet sie in ihr wesen und leutert
sie weit giftige und gesunde pflanzen
sind also nichts als leiter redete
gröbern zu vereinen teil
man könnte auch sagen
die pflanze betreibt schon in sich eine
form der aufklärung durch eine
niederschwellige die aufkleber
strukturellen anna logisch genau
dasselbe wie unsere läuterung der 5 das
ganze kunstwerk des gewächses ist
niedriges zu hören mehr hinauf zu binden
also wieder ein zentraler begriff hinaus
binden wirklich ganz interessant als und
vielleicht mama da eine grafik dazu dass
man diesem bildungsbegriff immer ein
bisschen klar war und ist analog hier
also eine struktur analogie zwischen
pflanze und auch menschen weil sie
letztendlich geht es hier um eine
bildung
hoppla jetzt habe ich den falschen stift
ausgewählt muss nämlich hier das
weil sie haben mir eine indoor bildung
und zwar die gilt sowohl für die
pflanzen die auch für den menschen
besteht darin dass materie wird geformt
und sublimieren
und beim menschen kann man sagen und
letztendlich auch bildung bildung und
aufklärung
diese diese da ist eine gewisse
entsprechung zu schmieden materie das
ist natürlich materie sind eben die
bestandteile wie wasser salz und hier
könnte man sagen aufklärung was wird
aufgeklärt
das wäre meinungen vielleicht einem und
gedanken als entsprechung pflanze
betreibt auch der aufklärung und der
menschen und ist ein kunstwerk ist ein
kunstwerk wird wir heute ja für die
pflanze schon komplizierten über der
pflanze steht das tier und zehrt von
ihren sehr viel und alles ganz geht es
analog weiter
die pflanze nimmt die elementaren
bestandteile wasser salz und zwei taufen
hirt sie das tier wiederum sublimiert in
pflanzen kühe fressen gras machen daraus
milch und so weiter zu fördern
der einzige der fantast ein grab von
millionen kräutern habe ist ein
lebendiges auswirken das grab er an ihm
amüsiert sie zu teilen
seine selbst den niedern kräfte gehen
auf eine reform des lebens über
sublimieren habe ich das hier ja zur
premiere feierte form
keiner der formeln und das gilt
natürlich auch für tiere tiere die
pflanzen fressen das ist eine premiere
so ist ein fleisch präsentieren die
natur hat die übergänge gemacht gleich
als sie sich vor allem langsam tote
befürchtet der ton wird er übrigens auf
substantiiert natur wird als ein akteur
gefasst wo der heute nie mehr unter
spannung
die natur ist und kein besuch so es wird
als präsentieren so weiter darauf
verkürzte sie und beschleunigte die wege
der transformation in höhere
lebensformen unter allen tieren ist das
geschäft der feinsten organe der
menschen der größte mörder
er kann einer alles was ein lebendiger
organisation nur nicht zu tief unter
entsteht in seinem tod verwaltet alle
ganz wichtiger begriff ist hier die
verwandlung oder die transformation
hans hauner zu muss man auch hier mit
offenen die transformation sind
transfers
dazu
sobald dem so ein bisschen im leben
steht das ja hertha davon spricht das
ist dieselbe form ist die heilung zu
können weil die pre formation im transit
zu machen formation wie sich das
zusammenhält reformation transformation
das entspannte aber es wird jedenfalls
alles summiert alles wird auf eine
höhere stufe
[Musik]
ja genau aufgehoben ist und wo der
begriff das hat was von diesen
schilderungen von einer dialektischen
fortschritt es ist alles wird auf eine
höhere ebene aufgehoben
das ist irgendwie negiert es auch
bewahrt auf einer höheren ebene gewarnt
und das ist letztendlich so ein
dialektisches modell was ich schon ganz
im prinzip bei herder findet durch
sogenannte spannend da jeder mensch muss
das vermögen hat mehrere kräfte sich
selbst zu assimilieren dass es gut sich
das aufnehmen so hatte auch das vermögen
sich gestärkt durch jene in der blüte
des lebens fortzubilden und den abdruck
seien selbst mit hand seine selbst mit
allen und in wirkenden kräften an seiner
stoff der wälder zu gehen fortbildungs
hier der zentrale begriff menschen
bereich herrscht die größte
mannigfaltigkeit von nike und anlagen
die wir oft als wunderbaren
widernatürlich an staunen aber nicht
begreift dann auf diese nicht ohne
organische gründe sein können so ließe
sich wenn uns überdies drohte der
schöpfung stellte einige vermutung
vergönnt ist das menschengeschlecht als
der große zusammenfluss nieder
organische kräfte ansehen die in ihm zur
bildung der humanität kommen soll
als die mieter reformen die pflanzen und
so weiter die sollen praktisch alle im
menschen zusammen laufen zeigt sie mal
dass alle vegetarier oder einer begangen
dass es gutes tiere zu essen weil darin
die tiere nur zu ihrer eigentlichen
bestimmung kommen nämlich
die menschen vergeistigten da kommt mir
könnte das auch noch pflanzen weil alles
strebt hier auf den menschen zu einem
sehr dynamischen hier bekommen sie es
ihren bestimmen das tier ist nur
insofern sie protestieren als gegessen
wurden als auf dem tisch macht das jetzt
mal zugespitzt
das hat nicht ganz spannung der
additiven kommen durch den menschen ihre
mobilität wenn sie gefressen gegessen
das reich der menschen organisation ist
ein system geistige kräfte des noch zum
schluss zu wir haben das jetzt nur von
natürlichen kräften von trieben von von
fleiß und so weiter und jetzt komme zu
den sublimieren kräften nämlich zu den
geistigen kräfte kurz gesagt erst dann
immer mal richtigen schuldenberatung
gegessen haben immer auch zu denken als
erste nach müsse ein bisschen ausruhen
schlafen aber erst dann komme gut denken
als unsere geistigen kräfte sind
angewiesen auf den natürlichen kräfte
das hellere bewusstsein dieser große
vorzug der menschlichen seele ist
derselben auf eine geistige weise und
zwar durch die humanität anmeldet erst
zu gebildet worden zu gebildet das
kürzel bisschen sich nach der genese
fast zu gewinnen
ein kind habe noch wenig bewusstsein auf
seine seele gleichzeitig setzt sich
unbeliebt zu demselben zu gelangen und
sich seiner selbst durch alle witze
gewisse alles ein streben nach begriffen
hat ihn zweck dieser welt gottes
gleichzeitig zu besinnen und sein
menschlich tief wurzeln das tier geht
noch im dunkeln traum her sein
bewusstsein ist es so viel reiz des
körpers verbreitet und von ihnen mächtig
umhüllt dass das helle der wachen zu
einer fortschritte den gedanken im
bewusstsein opposition nicht möglich
auch der mensch ist sich seines
innerlichen zustandes nur durch szene
bewusst und sobald diese laie ist gar
kein wunder dass in einer hersteller die
auch aus seiner eigenen anerkennung
hinweisen kann
und damit sich selbst vertraut oder
fröhliches trauma sprechen
und jetzt kommt der ausblick und
humanität und die knospen zu einer
zukünftigen blumen als er sagt jetzt
folgendes selbst der zustand des
menschen ist nicht ab so unternehmen
punkt in einem größeren kontext sehen
von dem aus zweiter schritt herum
wir sagen dass der zweck unseres
jetzigen dasein auf bildung der
humanität gerichtet sein der allem
niedrige bedürfnisse der erde nur dienen
und selbst zu erfüllen sollen dass es
wieder hier dieser punkt alles läuft auf
den menschen hinzu alles strebten auf
den menschen
mittelbar als prüftätigkeit fähigkeit
zur vernunft unsere fans gefallen sind
zu kunst uns betriebe zu recht freiheit
und schöne unserer bewegungs kräfte zu
menschen lieber gebildet werden entweder
wissen wir nichts von unserem bestehen
und die gottheit täuscht mit allen
anlagen von denen 1000 welche mester und
auch nicht an einen sinn hat oder wir
können dieses zwecks sicher sein als
gottes und unsere stars
heimat schon auf dass wir uns darüber
täuschen können ich mich blind eben zu
diesem diesen einwurf nimmt er mit auf
aber wichtig ist doch hier jetzt dass er
sagt die ganzen triebe sollen veredelt
werden uns natürlich anlagen zum
veredelt werden und zwar zur freiheit
also zur geistigen dimension mit gründen
zu operieren das finde ich entspannen
tut wissen jetzt am ende angekommen
sie haben und jetzt kommt am ende ist
der erfolg der jetzige zustand des
menschen ist wahrscheinlich das
verbindende mittel weder an zwei
unternehmen und die welt des gehalts die
tanzend interview als auch hier ist der
menschen unmittelbar punkt man muss noch
einen schritt weiter gehen natürlich
hoch spekulativ aber bis jetzt zusammen
zu fassen bevor wir dann in der nächsten
sitzung hierauf wörtlich blumenbar
eingehen welche setzen der sitzung nur
noch folgendes sagen also daher ist es
so alles was in der natur sich befindet
ist organisiert der tod sei ein großer
haushalt und diese haushalt gibt dazu
dass der mensch zu seinem ziel glanz im
taunus das ist humanität vernünftigkeit
frei auch künste schönheit hatte davon
gesprochen den westen zu tun oder der
match gelang nicht mittelbar dazu
sollten die pflanzen und
tiere gewissermaßen aufhebt könnte man
fast im ethischen sinn es sein als in
dem die triebe natürlichen triebe in ihm
gebündelt werden und vergeistigt wird
und so wie es sich die triebe im
menschen vergeistigung so vergeistigten
sie sich auch schon eine logisch
reformiert instruktor analogie in den
pflanzen tieren die tiere verdächtigen
die pflanzen und die pflanzen
vergeistigten die elementaren teile mit
salz und wasser um zu warten
dieses gibt es strukturen sieht man das
moment der aufhebung ist der vergeistigt
und das läuft jedenfalls beim menschen
auf so zählen aber wer das sagt der
mensch ist hier nur so teammitglied geht
es damit eine weitere welt mehr sind und
das ist dann so ein theologischer sprung
auf dem wir nicht näher eingehen müssen
aber hier kommt jedenfalls noch ein
weiterer prozess die menschen eigentlich
gehen kann gehen muss da kommt eine
theologische zum beispiel in der
nächsten sitzung fast simons mit johann
friedrich windolf und der hat ein ganz
zentralen begriff geprägt wissen sie
wieder weg heißt mit dem dom in
verbindung gebracht wird
bildung ist genau das der bildungsträger
werden
streep und hier sehen sie wieder beim
streep ist es der trieb das wer gebildet
werden wurde dass wir und bücherlesen
hier sich uns in unsere philosophie
veranstaltung einsetzen
so kann man bildung streep verstehen was
stark bildungsträger respekt oder man
könnte bildungsträger verstehen es ist
eben der tübinger natur der dazu führt
dass ich alles herausbildet alles
entwickelt evolutionstheorie tischen
gedanken wir müssen auch schon opa ein
epigenetischer ist oder eine
präsentation zu hängen muss man
natürlich auch sagen kann so das soll es
für heute gewesen sein
vielen dank für die gute mitarbeit und
bis zur nächsten sitzung